That there is an object in the mirror
that looks like ourselves
is beyond doubt, but it is not you.
I'm going to call it from now on
your 'other you'.
If you could examine
some of this creature's blood
then you'd find that the haemoglobin
molecules would be left-handed
whereas yours are right-handed,
dextro rotary haemoglobin
is the one that we use,
not the other one.
I wonder if we really know this other
person in the mirror.
Can we for example meet them anywhere in the universe?
Well, to some degree we can,
even in this theatre.
I want a volunteer now
to come and meet his other self,
and try and have a
conversation with him.
He has to be a very special volunteer
because in the first instance
I hope and pray
that one of you is called Stephen.
A Stephen?
Come along just the fella.
Now you've got to learn this new language,
and the first thing Stephen is that
your opposite number in the other world
is going to ask you your name,
and he will ask you in English
and so if he's been that polite,
the best the least you can do is to
reply in his language.
So first of all
I want you to learn his language,
you're going to say your name,
three times, 'Stephen, Stephen, Stephen',
into that microphone,
would you do that now?
just just turn to face the... that's it
"Stephen Stephen Stephen"
I think I'd spread them out a bit more Stephen
"Stephen Stephen"
That's it. Now we'll play back
and try and listen to what the man says.
And this is a translation.
[SPEECH PLAYED BACKWARDS]
Remember it, have a try saying it.
[SPEAKING BACKWARDS]
Fine, now we'll see how he heard it
"Stephen Stephen Stephen"
Didn't he do well?
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
It's not very difficult to learn this language,
See if you can manage
something more difficult now Stephen
and inquire about his state of health.
I'll have a go and then see
if you can do as well.
You want to say to him: "Hello how
are you? Hello how are you?"
Play it back from me.
[SPEECH PLAYED BACKWARDS]
[SPEAKS BACKWARDS]
Great game this.
[LAUGHTER]
[SPEECH PLAYED BACKWARDS]
Hello how are you? Hello how are you?
Alright?
[APPLAUSE]
Would you like to have a try?
Say it forward first twice.
How are you, how are you.
That'll do that's fine it's long enough
to remember, just saying how are you.
[SPEECH PLAYED BACKWARDS]
[SPEAKS BACKWARDS]
That's it.
[SPEECH PLAYED BACKWARDS]
Fine, thank you very much Stephen.
[APPLAUSE]
you